hello everybody and welcome to another
python 3 tutorial video uh this video is
going to be all about a module called cs
freeze and actually this module is not a
part of your standard library this is a
third party module and the idea of this
module is to convert your python scripts
into executable scripts so
just like making windows
not everybody cares to do this but some
people want to be able to distribute
their programs to others and actually
distribute them in a compiled form that
makes it a little bit harder for someone
to steal uh your work maybe um but also
it helps because if you say you want to
share your program with somebody you
don't want to be like you know hey check
out this cool graphing program uh just
download python matplotlib numpy six pi
parsing date util you know what i'm
saying like you don't have to tell them
like hey do all this stuff and then you
can use my little python script that i
made for myself no it'd be much nicer to
be able to be like here here's a zip
file unzip it run you know you know run
me.exe or whatever and
uh there's your you know my script for
you so that's what we're here to talk
about today and uh
for python 2.7
there's a module called pi to exe but
from what i found you there's no like
three python three support there
apparently you can like edit it or
something and then you can use it but cx
freeze does the exact same thing so why
bother so that's what we're going to be
using today is cx freeze now
again it's a third-party module so we're
gonna have to go find it download it
install it and we can use it now luckily
as uh as makes a whole lot of sense
there is a exe installer for cx freeze
so it's very simple so what you're going
to do to get it is you're going to head
over to your favorite google.com
and you're going to want to come down
here and go to their main website just
search for cx space freeze
basically the name freeze it's freezing
your program into an executable so uh
just for some background so click on
freeze
and then you'll come down here and it'll
say download and install latest version
was released may 3rd 2014 so as you can
see this is under active development
nice you can use pip install but we can
also install it directly from pi pi for
python package index
come over here and you see there's all
sorts of things that we can use this
python wheel i have never used a python
wheel before
in fact maybe someone comment below if
you know what the hell python wheel is
dot whl anyway someone let me know what
python wheel is or i might google it or
something but we're going to use
microsoft windows installer for python
3.4 so we'll download that still have my
pillow
down there uh install it uh maybe pause
the video while you're installing um
should be pretty quick installation by
the time
i'm done saying the sentence you should
be done installing it if you did
immediately run that
so
once you're done there uh we'll just
minimize this who was that sexy guy
uh and now we're ready to start uh
programming so the way that this works
is first you're gonna create something
that you wanna be distributed now for me
i just kind of want to use a program
that we've already written
so i'm going to go back through here and
let's take our url lib tutorial
so bring that up
and so this was the
the code from the url lib tutorial video
um so i'm going to go ahead and just
copy
this code and paste this code into here
and the idea here is just to show that
we can use um you know a module with
this
and basically what this is going to do
is it's going to search google it's
going to get some results it's going to
fake some headers for us
and i guess it's going to print maybe i
don't want to use this one
i wanted something a little easier more
basic
we'll see
what we got here
yeah let's use this code instead so i'm
going to copy and paste this code into
here
if you want this code i'll put a link to
the description
for this exact code i'll put it on my
website
so people can use it um just in case you
don't know all sample code is posted on
pythonprogramming.net
so this code and all like all of the
code for my at least recent videos and a
lot of the older videos is up there just
in case you're wanting it so what this
code does is it uses url lib visits
pythonprogramming.net
and basically just parses paragraph text
from it okay so using actually so we're
using url lib regular expressions so a
lot of python only stuff regular
expressions and all of that and we're
going to convert this to an executable
that anybody can run without needing
python 3.4 right or the re module
installed on their computer url lib all
this stuff so cool fancy
so um so we use this code like i said if
you don't have this code or you've got
your own code you use your own code if
you want to convert your own code to exe
or you can use this just for example
so this is our distributed file that we
want to use so i'm going to come over
here this is what i'm programming in
right now it's diss me so i'm gonna go
ahead and save that that saved it to
uh dissed me and now what i'm going to
do is i'll close out of this and now i'm
just going to copy and paste disk me and
we're going to call this file setup and
it's going to be setup dot pi
open that up
and
adjust just
okay like that
and now we want to do is i'm going to
clear everything okay so so we're now in
setup.pi okay so we've got two folders
in here we've got diskme which is
basically distribute me and then set up
the pi diskme is containing the code
that i want to distribute and now
setup.pi is going to be used
to tell cx freeze how to distribute this
basically
so our setup.pi file needs the following
so first of all we want to do from cx
underscore oops x underscore capital f
freeze from that import setup and
executable
okay
now we're going to want to do is we have
to define a bunch of stuff here so
basically we need to define
what are we going to
turn into an executable
what do we want to call that executable
and
you can give some other information you
can give descriptions you can give a
version number for example so we'll do
those those two things i suppose so what
we're going to do is we're going to say
setup
and then within setup you put a
basically a list of stuff so we're going
to say name
equals
we'll continue calling it diskme and
this is basically this means the name of
the exe so you could call it anything
you wanted you could say dist
uh we could say
url horse
okay
um comma and now let's do version this
is our very first version beta version
0.1 nice
uh description
equals
you know parse stuff for me put whatever
you want in there and then finally um
what we want to use is this executables
command
and so we're going to basically this is
what we convert to an executable so
executables
equals and then square brackets for our
list
and then we're going to use
executable so we're referencing this
executable
and
we're turning into an executable
distme.pi
and that's it so this is our setup.pi
file so we can save that and now we can
close that
and um now we've got our diskme and a
setup.pi
now what you can do uh
to make this easy is for example my file
here is located you know desktop syntax
license python three python three four
four cx-free cx tutorial
i come back here this is where i'm
coding in so i can literally write or
use the left hold down shift right click
and open the command window here
so that opens up this pretty thing
now what we can do
is run
uh we use python as our command python
setup.pi
build
and you have to use this in the in the
in the
directory that you that this file is in
if it's not you don't have to say
python. you could say python's you know
c colon slash uh users desktop
uh you know let's say it was on the
desktop you know setup.high build you
could do that so you don't have to you
know be in the same directory but it
helps it makes it easier to type so
setup dot pi
build
so we hit enter
and we wait hopefully this runs let's
see x q okay we
type executables so let's head over
to setup here
right click x
okay
executable
save it executables executable okay
hopefully this will run this time
um
come back over here and literally just
hit the up arrow for me anyway maybe
your build worked because you know how
to spell
anyway so that's it you should get this
massive amount of um
gobbledygook that comes out
so we'll go ahead and minimize this for
now or we'll just move it over i guess
and now you should have a folder called
build click on build and then you've got
this exe win amd 64 3.4 and within there
you have this me
so we can click on diskme
and basically what we get here is we run
it and it it visits my website found 27
search results basics um so it's
searching
um
basically my what it did i guess
actually what it's doing is it searches
basics on mypythonprogramming.net
and then basically what it did is print
out
all of our paragraph data from the
website but anyway as you can see those
we were able to run all of this with an
exe and so really you could send this to
your friend right we could send someone
if they've got a 64-bit 3.4
windows machine they could go here click
on diskme and they could run this
program if they've never installed
python they don't have url lib regular
expressions anything they will still be
able to run
this and that's because in here
is where they get all of the data that
they really truly need um it's all
located in here so
um
that should be it as far as using any
any sort of either cx freeze uh potty
exe is very similar as well but this was
with cx freeze
and that's it it's pretty simple for
most packages you can get away with this
if the package also has a gui with like
t kinter and
or is very graphical based uh you might
have some trouble with it
um like matplotlib it's very difficult
to get matplotlib to work with pi to exe
or even cx freeze but as far as your
typical program is concerned you should
have no problem with this it should just
take all the modules and run
matplotlib has an issue with
when to run specific things and that's
what what makes it fail but
anyway
that should be it for this one if you
guys have any questions or comments
something not working out for you or you
couldn't get this far uh please feel
free to leave them below if i forget to
link to uh this in the description uh
remind me and i'll put a link to it in
the descriptions so you can use my code
but i encourage you to use whatever code
you want to convert to a
exe really shouldn't matter maybe you
can find some more code that you're
having trouble with um
that for whatever reason isn't
converting to a uh
exe
so that's going to conclude this video
if you guys um said questions or
comments link below as always thanks for
watching thanks for all the support and
subscriptions until next time